fold up your Grillo portable barbecue
and pack your post-apocalyptic food in a
tactical lunchbox because it's episode
41 of loop improve your skills on the
court with the 9450 skit ball it
measures everything from ball handling
and shot accuracy to shot speed and spin
acceleration and the information is
updated from ball to app in 100
milliseconds get ready for summer from
the inside out with an anatomical
bathing suit and while you're at the
beach watch for a whale bottle opener to
crack open a drink and pour into a cup
that is floating in a palm tree drink
raft kept cold with your ground cooler
the e cool is a year-round drink cooler
that doesn't use electricity because it
uses the earth trust your gut and make
an executive decision with your morning
coffee like the decision to eat
chocolate sausage that might come with
its own chopping board and knife but
doesn't come with a nose spoon continue
to play with your senses using aroma
forks there are 21 aromas to choose from
so you can mix and match to trick your
palate into believing you're eating
almost anything if you can't make it
taste like bacon just wear it on this
charm bracelet then get your fortune and
a sugar high with fortune-telling
cupcake liners and match your mood with
these roll-on perfumes for those who
chose play make sure to get a slide
writer that turns your stairs into a
slide and I mean what else can I say it
turns your stairs into a slide use Auto
to capture your happy slide face and
turn it into an animated gif or Jif it's
a hackable customizable digital camera
that automatically shares your photos
with your smartphone next show off your
Google glass because you're so rich you
can make it rain confetti make just
about anything with the m3d the first
consumer 3d printer that can be used by
beginners it's now available for
pre-order and will fit nicely next to
your but station desk accessory get off
your button fly a paper airplane with a
smartphone the powerup 3.0 has a 100
80 foot range and flies for 10 minutes
per charge once you fold and attach just
connect to your phone and fly away from
a terrifying mask of your own face calm
down and listen to something slow in
these custom slug headphones all while
you snuggle up with the classic book
pillow play with a new spin on a classic
using smart Mass Thinking Putty which
comes in styles ranging from unicorn
tears to magnetic giant lizard green
then thumbs down your friends in the
thumb wrestling arena and take your fish
for a walk with the help of fish on
wheels that lets the fish to the
steering by detecting the direction that
it's swimming finally after all that I
must say that I'm glad you're as weird
as me
greeting cards and as always thanks for
watching